Once you've initialized your array,
chances are you're going to
want to add or remove items.
To add an item to the end of an array,
I can use the append method like this.
Or to add an item to
a specific place in an array,
I can use the method, insert at index.
To remove an item,
you use the method, remove it index.
So for example,
to take out Flo Rida, we need to
specify that he's at index three.
But I don't think this playlist
has enough country music, so
we'll insert Keith Urban, and
we'll put him at index three.
And then if we look over
here in our sidebar,
we can see that Keith Urban
has been added to the array.
If I want to know how many items are in
my array, I can use the count method.
If I want to retrieve an item,
I can do so using sub script syntax.
I just write the name of the array, and
at the end, add the items index as
a sub script between square brackets.
And here in the sidebar we can see that
the value Dej Loaf has been assigned to
the constant musician.
We've written exercises to give you
plenty of practice working with arrays.
I think you'll find the syntax
to be fairly intuitive.
For now, let's continue on to
dictionaries in the next section.